My name is Dr. Adam
Hurst. I'm a general
pediatrician in the
clinical medicine
department here
today with a lecture
on attention deficit
hyperactivity
disorder and
adolescent development.
If you have any
questions as you go
through this
lecture, please don't
hesitate to email
me. It's included on
this first slide.
I'd be happy to help.
For Attention Deficit
Hyperactivity
Disorder, or ADHD,
and that's what
I'll refer to it
as as the lecture
goes on, I'm
going to start and
just cover this
as the first half
of the lecture.
Here are some
objectives specifically
for ADHD. So
recognizing the core
symptoms and
presentations of ADHD, the
diagnostic criteria,
outlining the
steps to evaluating
a child with ADHD.
We'll talk about the
four different types
of ADHD along with
the comorbidities
that are common and
recognizing these.
And then summarizing
briefly the
ADHD treatment
based upon age.
Now as you go
through this lecture
there might be some
stars in the bottom
right hand corner
that will refer
back to session
objectives. There's also
some bolded and
underlined parts
that will be critical
teaching things.
So before learning
about the presentation
or pathophysiology of
any disorder or disease
that you come across
from clinical side
point, it's important
to understand the
epidemiology. It helps
you understand how
the disease alters the
world, gives us clues
about who may be at
risk for it, gets an
overall picture of how
many patients may be
experiencing this on
a day-to-day basis.
In regards to ADHD,
it's estimated to
affect almost 9% of
children in the
United States, with an
incidence only
increasing as more
studies and more data
is being collected.
It's also important
to know that
boys are twice
as likely than
girls to be
diagnosed with ADHD.
Now, unlike many
other disorders,
there's no specific
association
for a race or ethnicity.
However,
there is an increased
incidence in ADHD
in children with
other disorders,
whether it's a
neurologic, developmental,
psychiatric, or a
genetic disorder.
Now, a few of these
examples, tuberous
sclerosis, autism
spectrum disorder,
anxiety, fragile
When you look at
the risk factors for
ADHD, the main point
to understand is
there's no singular
risk factor for ADHD,
but actually, it's a
wide mix of genetic,
biological, and
environmental factors.
Some of the important
ones to pull
out from an
environmental factor,
having prenatal
smoke exposure,
prenatal alcohol
exposure, lead
exposure, all
increases that risk.
From a biological
standpoint, a low birth
weight and prematurity
are some of the main
risk factors that are
commonly seen. Now
this is not an extensive
list, but it's just
a few of the important
ones that you would
clinically now getting
into the presentation
of ADHD the specific
definition of ADHD ADHD
is a heterogeneous
neurodevelopmental
disorder that's
characterized by symptoms of
inattention motor
hyperactivity and impulsivity
that is inappropriate
for developmental stage
now what that really
means is that we expect
there to be levels
of inattention
hyperactivity and impulsivity
for any kid. However,
a child with ADHD will
have those symptoms
that exceed that level
compared to other
children at their
developmental stage and age.
It's really important
to understand that no
two children with ADHD
will look alike. We
might say that the
same presentation on
paper or on a test,
however in the clinical
standpoint, one child
will look very different
than another child or
in regards to ADHD.
Also thinking about
ADHD, while it's
extremely common
in children, it's
also very common in
adulthood as well.
While ADHD
symptoms though are
more manageable
as age goes on,
there are about 60
% of adults who have
had ADHD symptoms
during childhood
that continue to
have those symptoms
that interfere with
their daily living.
The criteria for
ADHD diagnosis,
as you'll see, just
like with a lot of other
developmental and
psychiatric disorders,
it comes from the DSM
-5 that these criteria
must be met in order
to diagnose a patient.
Understanding
these criteria
are really important.
It's not memorizing
this word for word, but
getting the overall
symptoms and criteria.
And so according
to DSM-5, ADHD is
characterized by a
persistent pattern of
inattentiveness and
hyperactivity impulsivity
and or hyperactivity
impulsivity that
interferes with
functioning or development.
Now the last part,
interfering with
functioning, it might
also be referred to
as functional
impairment, is very
important because for
ADHD you have to have
that impairment
with your symptoms.
Now you need six or
more symptoms from
either of the categories
in attendiveness
and or hyperactivity
impulsivity that
are causing functional
impairment and have
been present for at
least six months.
The symptom onset
must be prior to 12
years of age and
symptoms must be present
in two or more
settings, and commonly
that's school and
home for children.
And just like with
many other psychiatric
and developmental
disorders, the symptoms
can't be explained
by another disorder.
Now before I move on,
a point to clarify
that could be
confusing is that
while ADHD symptoms
must be present
prior to 12 years
of age, that doesn't
mean you have to be
diagnosed with ADHD
before the age of
12. For example,
an undergraduate
student who's 22 could
have no prior medical
history but be
diagnosed with ADHD as
long as they can recall
symptoms of
hyperactivity and or
endotinomous that began
before the age of 12.
And it's also one side
point to point out
for DSM-5, if you're
diagnosing a patient
17 years or older,
it's the same criteria.
So again, symptoms
that have been present
for at least six months,
causing functional
impairment in two
or more settings
prior to 12 years of
age. However, they
only need five of
those symptoms or more.
Now we'll go over the
four main types of ADHD.
You have ADHD
inattention,
ADHD hyperactive
impulsive,
ADHD combined, which
is both inattention
and hyperactive
impulsive, or there's
the ADHD other specified
or unspecified.
And we'll walk
through each of those
criteria need.
However, the main point
is having at least
six or more of the
nine symptoms for
at least six months.
Now this is a slide
put together that
breaks down the
specific symptoms. So in
the blue are the
inattentive symptoms,
red you have hyperactive,
and the yellow
being impulsive. And
so to be diagnosed
with ADHD inattention,
you have to have
six of these nine
symptoms. Now, don't
memorize each one
of these presenting
symptoms, but just read
through them, be aware
of some of the
common symptoms that
would be associated
with inattentive type.
The same for the
hyperactive and impulsive.
To be diagnosed with
that ADHD type, you have
to have at least six
out of the nine of
any of these hyperactive
and impulsive types.
And to be diagnosed
with the combined
type, you need at
least six of the nine
from the inattentive
and six of the nine
from the hyperactive
and impulsive side.
For the other specified
or unspecified, while
you might not meet the
criteria of six out
of the nine, it's still
clinically significant
symptoms causing
functional impairment.
The main three
types that seen in
practice are the
inattention, hyperactive,
impulsive, or the
combined types.
And again,
don't memorize all these
symptoms, but thinking
from the standpoint
of diagnosing ADHD,
the patient's coming with
difficulty sustaining
attention and task
or play activities,
can't organize task
activities,
easily distracted,
the child that's
fidgety with
their hands or
feet, or can't
sit still,
always on the go,
and the impulsive,
can't wait
for his turn,
blurts out answers.
Again, symptoms
that you'll commonly
see in children, it's
being all of those
symptoms together,
with the duration
of symptoms and
the functional
impairment that helps
with the diagnosis.
So, now that you
understand the
presentation, so again,
all those symptoms,
the diagnostic criteria,
so we need to figure
out how to diagnose
the child. It's
important to take the
steps from a physician's
standpoint because
it could be something
else. And so, the
main tools that
you're going to use to
diagnose ADHD are starting
with your history.
You'll also need a
good physical exam
and then utilizing
an ADHD rating scale.
Now, the patient
history is
probably the most
important aspect
of evaluating a
child for ADHD.
Many developmental and
psychiatric disorders
are very different
than medical
diagnosis because there's
not a specific blood
test or image that
can help diagnose.
So you really need
a good comprehensive
history from the
patient and the family.
And so you need
behaviors at home
and at school or
the other common
setting the student
is found in.
Sometimes too, if
they are very involved
with sports or another
activity, getting
that tutor, that
teacher, that coach,
that input as well
can be super helpful.
Getting into a thorough
family history,
a very in-depth
social history
along with that
school history as
you're walking through
the evaluation.
And when you ask about
the child's behavior
both at school and at
home, because again
ADHD requires the
symptoms to be present
across two or more
different social settings.
A few points with
the family history,
because commonly there
will be other family
members that have
a history of ADHD,
learning disabilities,
or mental illness,
whether it's anxiety
or depression,
and so getting a
good family history.
From the social
history standpoint,
trying to see if
there's any recent
stressors or sudden
family changes, trauma,
sleep issues that
could be a trigger
or be causing some
of their symptoms.
And from a school history
standpoint, trying
to see to what's
happening at the school.
Are they having worsening
grades? Are they
having sudden behavior
issues, suspensions,
behavior problems? Are
they just disruptive in
class? Trying to get
some more details on
the school issues that
the patient is having.
Now, as you move on
to a physical exam,
it's important to
help rule out other
potential diagnoses
that could be
contributing or
causing the symptoms.
It's also very
important from a
baseline standpoint
if it is ADHD.
And so getting a good
set of vitals, so
having a good
height, weight, blood
pressure, and pulse.
Now, as you would learn
about their treatment,
if the patient
is diagnosed with
ADHD, first line would
be stimulants,
depending on their age.
And those stimulant
medications can
increase their heart
rate, increase their
blood pressure,
decrease their
appetite, and cause
weight loss. And so
having a good
baseline prior to the
initiation of treatment
is very important.
Physical exam can
also help you rule
out other conditions
or disorders that
could be
contributing to those
symptoms. And so
assessing their language
development, How
is their behavior,
their social interaction
on your exam?
Always assessing for
hearing and vision
deficits because
having a vision
disorder or a hearing
deficit can present
with those problems,
causing issues
of sustaining that
attention or impulsivity
especially in a
school setting.
So from that physical
exam standpoint,
having those
good baselines,
being able to rule
out other conditions,
making sure that
their thyroid is not
enlarged, that their
heart is appropriate,
the rhythm, the rate,
having a good overall
physical exam can help
rule out disorders
and ensure that
before you initiate
treatment and as you
continue to help your
patient that they're
set up for success.
final step would be
the utilization of
an ADHD rating scale
now there's several
different types of
ADHD rating scales and
because your ADHD
symptoms aren't going
to show up in the
office visit that you
have 10 or 15 minutes
to walk through all
the extensive history
and the thorough
physical exam the
rating Scale can be
super helpful to give
the parent some time
to think back and
record the symptoms and
record the impairment
that's going on.
One of the common
ones is the
Vanderbilt Writing
Scale, it has
both a teacher
and a parent form.
And so in clinic you
provide the parent
with both of these,
the parent can fill it
out in the room and
give it back, but the
teacher will get it
and ideally mail it
back, fax it back,
give it to the parent.
But getting that
thorough history from
multiple settings to
help with your diagnosis.
Now those rating
scales, whether it's the
Vanderbilt or the
other types, are based
on that DSM-5 criteria
and help assess
the degree of the
functional impairment.
But the main
point to know is
rating scales are
not diagnostic.
There's no rating
scale that should be
used alone to make the
diagnosis. It's your
history, your exam,
it's these scales that
help clarify the
criteria and in multiple
settings that help
with the diagnosis.
The rating scales will
help document those
presence of symptoms.
They can also be helpful
to reference back
after treatment is
initiated to look back
and see what the symptoms
were and are they
getting better, are they
worse, is that impairment
better? or is the
impairment not improved
with your treatment.
So as we move
into what common
comorbidities can
be found with ADHD,
most commonly it's
associated with other
emotional or behavioral
comorbidities,
oppositional defiant
disorder, conduct
disorder being some
of the most common,
depression, anxiety,
substance use or *****,
intermittent
explosive disorder.
From developmental
comorbidity standpoint,
specific learning
disorders are commonly
found, along with
language or speech
disorders and autism
spectrum disorders.
And sometimes you
can also have a
sleep disorder or
a tick disorder.
I think it's the main
point down here, it's
just important to
have a low threshold
when assessing for
comorbidities, because
not every behavior
will be caused by ADHD.
Now, that does not
mean your patient
doesn't have ADHD,
but maybe the most
worrisome symptoms
the patient and the
parents present with
could be because
of comorbidity
along with the ADHD.
While this is just
a sample list of
some common comorbidities,
you don't have
to memorize each
specific one, but
remembering that
oppositional defiant
disorder can be found
in approximately
half a children with
combined type ADHD.
And so some of
these can be very
common in our
patients with ADHD.
Now, we'll start
with just the very
overall goals of
management with ADHD.
You're going to get
a separate lecture
that goes into the
specific pharmacological
management. But
for this lecture,
just kind of going
through first-line
treatments based really
upon the patient's
age, which almost
always includes a
combination of
behavioral interventions,
educational
interventions,
and likely medication.
So if your patient
is under six,
they should always
be treated first
with parent
training behavioral
management as the
first line approach.
Now, PTBM or parent
behavior therapy or
parent training is a
program that allows parents
to become trained
in behavior therapy.
They help them
understand the
child's behavior
and manage it with
appropriate
coping strategies.
It helps a lot with
that child to have
success at home and to
pass those tips on to
the teachers. So to
help with school, help
with home, help with
those relationships.
However, if the
parent training and
behavioral management
alone is not successful,
the child can be
prescribed medication.
If they're under
the age of six, it's
important to remember
that methylphenidate
would be the first
line rather than
an amphetamine
medication at that age.
Now, if your children
is over the age of
six, medication is
the first line, and a
stimulant medication
is the first line
therapy of choice,
but often that is
supplemented with various
behavioral modifications,
and whether that's
parent training,
behavioral management,
or counseling,
it's variable based
upon the child and what
the other symptoms
and history reveals.
What the important
part is is having good
communication, being
there and to have
good goals with the
patient, the family,
passing those on to
the school, so that way
you can have effective
management And
commonly, it's a team
approach, especially
with a lot of
pediatric behavioral or
psychiatric disorders
that you're getting a
psychologist, maybe a
developmental pediatrician
involved, if you are
having unsuccessful
treatment with
medications, if there's
comorbidities
involved, if there's a
language or speech
impairment, using therapists
to help in their
day-to-day symptoms.
Okay, so that would
conclude the half
of the lecture about
ADHD, and again,
we went through
the core symptoms,
presentation, your
diagnostic criteria,
your evaluation,
so your physical
exam, your history
that's very in
-depth, and any kind
of rating scales.
You all understand
the four different
types, along with the
common comorbidities,
and then a very
simple, brief,
general overview
for ADHD treatments.
So as we move on
to that adolescent
development and
adolescent care
portion, again, we've
covered a lot and
this will kind
of just be a very
overview of adolescent
development.
So some objectives
for this part of the
lecture is recognizing
the key features and
subtypes of adolescent
development, explaining
the focus of adolescent
well visit. So,
going through the
psychosocial history,
anticipatory guidance
for these age groups,
and screening for
risk-taking behaviors.
And also understanding
the areas
of adolescent
care that can
and cannot remain
confidential.
So, adolescence is
defined as a critical
period of growth
that is characterized
as a gradual
development towards
autonomy in adult
decision-making.
Now, you can break
adolescence down.
Now, these ages are
not a very exact
number, it's a range,
and so commonly
it's between the
ages of 11 and 21.
So having early
adolescence around the
ages of 11 through
14, middle adolescence
ages 15 to 17, and
late adolescence being
around the ages of 18
to 21 years of age.
Now, it's not important
to memorize the
exact age ranges,
but have that general
idea of the stage
that they're in.
It's also really
important to
understand that
adolescents are a
really unique
patient population.
They are very vulnerable
and have a wide
range of needs from
unmet emotional
or medical needs and
that transitioning
towards adulthood
is very challenging.
But as they make
that transition
towards adulthood,
they can help
predict poor
health outcomes.
How is their
quality of life
going to be in adulthood?
And so being able to
have that good, safe
medical home for
your patient is super
important. And helping
that adolescent grow
and adjust is helpful
as the years go on.
Now, for the four key
areas of development
that occur in adolescence,
having biological
development,
cognitive development,
psychosocial, and
emotional development.
And we'll briefly
go through three of
those, biological
development being growth
and development. So,
going through puberty,
those pubertal
changes, this lecture
mostly focusing more
on the cognitive,
psychosocial, and the
emotional development.
From the cognitive
development, it's
an adjustment in
their thinking.
And so early
adolescence, they
have that very
concrete thinking.
The patient's
ability to think only
about things that
they have had direct
contact with or direct
knowledge of. So
they will only be
able to solve a
problem with real
objects or facts that
they know. There's
really no hypothetical
thinking in those
concrete brains.
As they develop, they
now become abstract
thinkers. So now they
can think when they
have that ability to
imagine things that
they've never yet
seen or experienced,
and so can start
thinking out of the box.
And then that
continues to transition
into starting to have
reasoning skills.
Concrete thinkers
aren't often able to
understand the consequences
of their actions,
and so therefore
wouldn't be able to
link the cause and
effect of their health
and the behaviors
that they're doing.
As they continue
to transition into
that abstract thinking,
they slowly start
to develop the
ability to explore
the possible
consequences of their
actions through that
hypothetical thinking,
through a logical
thought process.
so now that they're
having to be able to
think cause and effect
now they continue to
grow up and start having
formal operational
thinking and so that
really requires a big
step and it's called
metacognition it's
really that ability to
think about thinking
late adolescent patients
are often able to
think about what they're
feeling and how others
perceive them it's an
important aspect of
development And if
this stage of thinking
develops improperly,
which commonly it will,
it can cause many
adolescents to
develop that
imaginary audience.
And so an imaginary
audience, the
patient thinks that
everyone is focused
on them and
thinking about them.
It's a very egocentric
way of thinking that
they can be very
detrimental in the
already very sensitive
stage of development.
So as you think about
your own transition
from being that
concrete, fixed thinker
to being able to have
abstract thinking,
thinking out of the
box, and how that helps
you form that
operational thinking of
this caused this and
how I'm perceived as
you go through that
adolescent stage, it
takes a long time to
develop that process.
In addition to
cognitive development,
adolescent patients
will also go through
psychosocial and
emotional changes.
Psychosocial
development often
entails developing
autonomy,
establishing one's
own identity,
developing that
future orientation.
Developing autonomy
can be very broad.
Commonly though,
there's two common
examples in
developing that
emotional and
economical independence.
And so
understanding, hey,
maybe they got
their first job
and now they can
start growing
and figuring out how
to use their first
paycheck and they
have their first
relationships that
maybe get broken up and
dealing with that
emotional independence.
as they have that
independence, that autonomy
they're also learning
to establish their
identity commonly
that's characterized by
a building of self
-concept self-esteem,
self-esteem, experimentation
and rebellion.
Self-concept
referring to the
patient's perception
of their self.
How are their
talents their
goals? What life
experiences are
being remembered by them,
what's their
participation in different
ethnic, religious,
****** identity groups.
On the other hand,
self-esteem is how the
patient assesses their
own self-worth. And
so you have that self
-concept of what's
that perception of
their self, whereas the
self-esteem is what's
their self-worth.
Future orientation
relates to the patient's
goals for their
future career that
they're developing but
this time in adolescence
is often when
patients begin to
establish the values
that are important to
them in life and so
if you think too those
are very important
huge aspects in
developing a person and
that patient is going
through in adolescence
and so lastly
emotional development
primarily entails
development of emotional
social confidence.
Emotional confidence
referring to the
patient's ability to
manage their own emotions
and identify and label
their own feelings.
That can be very
challenging for adults.
And so thinking,
hey, it's going to
take a long time for
them to learn that.
Social confidence, on
the other hand, refers
to the patient's
ability to relate with
others and identify
the feelings of others.
So if you take a
second, there was a lot
that I just talked
through this slide.
That's adolescence
It can be a whole
lot, and this is
just a general
idea of those
developmental phases
that are going
through those years.
Now that we've
gone through the
various areas
of development
that occur during
adolescence,
it's important to note
that these different
areas don't always
develop synchronously.
Often, emotional
development lags behind
the others. And most
commonly, it's an
emotional-physical
asynchrony that often
causes adolescents
to be treated older
than their emotional
stage of development.
So thinking about
children now developing
physically, that they
look like teenagers,
or teenagers have
developed and they look
like young adults, that
they're treated like
a young adult or
treated like a teenager.
However, that
just leads to
increased risk
-taking behaviors.
And whether that's
drugs, alcohol,
vaping, unprotected
***, if they're being
treated as older
individuals, however,
that emotional
development has not
matured, increased
risk for all the
risks of adolescent
and teenage years.
Now, that's what makes
an adolescent visit
very important
because you can really
establish trust where
they will listen
to your preventative
counseling, they'll
listen to your
anticipatory guidance on
what they should and
shouldn't be doing at
this age and this
stage of their life.
Now,
with adolescent being
a very unique and
vulnerable time period
for our patients,
unfortunately studies
have found that
over 20% of
adolescents have a
mental health
disorder and more than
And 50% of lifetime
cases of mental
illness began around
the age of 14.
Patients aged
10 to 24 years
old count for
14% of suicides.
And suicide is the
leading cause of death
in patients aged
10 to 14 years old.
That doesn't just
make us sad as
providers trying
to be proactive and
talking about our
adolescent mental
health and our
adolescent development.
Our youth and young
adults account for
the highest percentage
of emergency
department visits
relating to self-harm.
These points just
show how vital it is
to both understand
the emotional and
physical turbulence
that our adolescent
patients are going
through and that we
have to be there to
provide a safe and
trusted medical
home to our patients
so that they know
where they can go. So
now that you understand
the turbulent
period of
adolescence, you
can help us
understand now as a
physician, how do
we approach that?
And the main goal is
building that
relationship,
getting a good
history, understanding
what your patient's
going through.
And so taking a thorough
psychosocial history
and screening for
risk-taking behaviors
are two primary goals
of the office visit.
You can memorize that
mnemonic heads, so
covering their home
situation, home
environment, education,
employment, how are
they eating, are
they exercising, what
activities are they
partaking in, are they
using any drugs,
what's their sexuality,
are they having
any suicide or
depressive symptoms,
and are they safe.
Now, when possible,
it's really nice to talk
to that patient
alone. That helps you
establish trust with
your patient while
encouraging that sense of
autonomy and independence
that they're growing
inside themselves.
Now that makes it
a conversation with
family, whether
that's a grandparent,
a parent, a step
-parent, being able
to ask that there's
permission to talk
to their patient
alone to help build
that trust. And
that's the rationale.
I like to interview
my teenager patients
without a parent in the
room so that way they
can feel safe to
answer the questions
truthfully, even if the
parent knows all of it.
And so establishing
that early on
in your well-child
visits and your well
-teenager visits so that
way it's understood
when you get to a
psychosocial history
that the parent or
guardian will be stepped
out so you can talk
to the patient alone.
You've gotten that
thorough psychosocial
history and given
that patient a trusted
space to communicate
with you. You also
want to screen for
risk-taking behaviors,
so making sure to ask
for any type of risk
-taking behavior, but
also thanking them.
Thank you for
sharing. Thank
you for telling
me these things.
Provide anticipatory
guidance when it's
appropriate, And now
that's when you're giving
that information
about the benefits of
healthy lifestyles,
healthy practices,
that's going to promote
the prevention of
disease, of injury,
especially in teenagers.
And so helping
them understand the
potential that those
behaviors can cause
on their health,
on their future.
Now a final point
about adolescence is
confidentiality. And
so we talked about the
range, and this can
be anywhere between
11 years of age up to
21 years of age. So
providing a whole lot
between those ages.
And so being able to
understand when am I
having to provide this
confidentially, what
is age of consent, and
that varies by state
or by the service
that you're providing.
And so, making sure
that you're aware in
your state of what
situation and what criteria
is met with consent
and confidentiality.
Physicians should
deliver confidential
health services
in situations
involving reproductive
health, sexuality,
gender identity
and expression,
substance use, and mental
health to
consenting adults.
And now remember
that emancipated
minors may consent
for themselves
in all manners
of treatment.
And so while you can
provide a confidential
source for your
patient to disclose
information regarding
those criteria,
there are some
exceptions that mean you
have to report to the
proper authority. And
so if your patient
discloses suggesting
that someone's in
imminent danger, if you
suspect because of
the history any ******
or physical *****
going on of that child
or another individual
that they disclose,
you have to break
that confidentiality.
Or if it's a
diagnosis of a
communicable
disease, you have to
disclose that
confidentiality.
And so while it needs
to be a safe place
for your patient to
disclose information,
if they reveal
something to you
and you have to
report it, it's
helpful to tell
them beforehand.
Unfortunately, I have
to tell someone about
this and making sure
that they know and
understand why so
that way you're not
breaking their trust
and that way they can
continue to disclose
information to you.
But there are some
exceptions to be known.
So we got through
adolescence, which is a
very wide range, and
now just kind of going
through a few key
points of the lecture.
So we covered
ADHD, so ADHD is a
neurodevelopmental disorder
that causes functional
impairment and requires
specific criteria.
So having at least
six of nine symptoms
present for at
least six months,
symptoms need to be
present before the age
of 12 and symptoms need
to be present in two
or more settings and
also cannot be explained
by another disorder
and then we covered
our adolescence and
so that unique and
vulnerable transitional
period for our patients
and that primary goal
of adolescent their
well visit is
anticipatory guidance it's
getting a thorough
psychosocial history
screening for risk-taking
behaviors, building
that trust in that
relationship, and then
briefly touched on
confidentiality and when it
should be expected
for consenting adults.
We have confidential
in relations to
reproductive health,
sexuality, gender
identity, substance
use, and mental health.
So, I've, there's a
few questions here
that we could just walk
through, um, within
the notes, the answers
are provided, um,
and so, but if you come
across any of these
questions and it doesn't
make sense, please
reach out. I'm gonna
click through these,
but again,
please just reach
out if any of these, um,
don't make sense of
what that rationale
is. and here are
some references,
but the lecture
feedback form and along
with my contact
information. So please
reach out and ask
me any questions.
Hope you have a good
rest of the day.